our next guest Drew she was a cast
member on your favorite show and she is
your birthday twin she was here last
year for her birthday
it's a tradition please welcome Rachel
Drive
[Applause]
I brought you a emotional support mac
and cheese
needs some emotional support right now
because it's a very emotional day and
we're Pisces we're both Pisces it's the
last side on the chart they say the most
intuitive most wise of course yeah and
it's your birthday too
[Applause]
also not only this there's also real mac
and cheese here oh you told me look at
this oh do you know what's so crazy I'm
so flipped out right now I'm not hungry
what oh wow when your body's going like
this you can eat it all uh-uh no okay by
the way she spun out but I will keep it
for for later they said it's in a cloche
they said this was a cloche so let me
ask you something Rachel yes I
I have seen you many times on the John
Oliver show yes yeah
yes I play his wife Wanda Joe yeah and
it started as like a televangelist wife
and my hair just keeps getting bigger
and bigger yeah
[Applause]
what's he like
um he's I mean you just saw him right
he's like fantastic he's my husband he's
my chibi husband so
um he's fantastic I mean I'm it's been
so fun seeing you get so surprised yes I
know and I'm like and then Here Comes me
are you kidding me
so much
and like I just I I it's so funny I mean
do you know how much like every day of
my life also like I quote you as Debbie
oh my gosh yes
feline AIDS is the number one killer of
cat yeah
I should be down there right now uh just
I could I don't know just I don't know
what would you like for your birthday
more than anything else yeah because you
have too much successor Tony nominated
actress hello
yes it's true yeah with my hero John
Oliver you're a comedic Queen and genius
wow foreign
but I will say I'm I'm pretty good at
manifesting things like like I try to
like say it and then things do kind of
come true for me so I should think of
something right yeah
what do you want I
bet you I just want my kids to be okay
like that's all I want good see that's
again you thought of others well I know
what I wanted it's not even my birthday
I want to hit some headlines I want you
to take on this
so people reports baseball star Derek
Jeter revealed the unexpected way he
broke out of a terrible slump it was
2004 and Jeter was over 32 and in a
desperate need of a hit so he borrowed a
teammates tried and true good luck charm
it was a golden thong hi I like this
headline right and as soon as he put
that thong on he hit a home run so thank
you
I'm wondering would you guys if you were
ever in a slump would you borrow a
friend's thong and just put it on I mean
of all the underwear to choose that
really gets in the orifices and like
this so I I mean wow that's a flossy
come like intimacy yeah I think I would
I think I would decline and just hope
for the the luck of the Gods as opposed
to putting on a friend sometimes call
for desperate situation right I've done
much grosser I had to think do I know a
friend who wears a gold thong and then
yeah I do I do so I would I would
totally borrow it yeah come on man you
gotta get home run now do what you need
to do really I would borrow your
underwear because as George always tells
us she wears really big Underwear by the
way I heard you said I fear Ross they
would be too big for you you'd need like
a diaper pen in that all right uh well
Drew we have a story for you actually
next if you want to take this and you
again you have not seen this story nope
this is Fresh Off The Fresh okay
um next bustle reports on a flirting
technique going viral on Tick Tock it's
a way to let someone know that you're
into them without saying it it's called
The Triangle method yeah the triangle
method and I want to demonstrate here's
how it works so if you want to flirt
with someone when you're face to face
with your crush you trace your eyes in
the shape of a triangle by looking at
first in their left eye then down to
their mouth
and then to the right eye the way that
far down you look look like I know I was
looking I was looking a little too a
little too low my mouth's up here
Matthews right so let do you want to try
it on me flu let me try it on you right
I don't try to Rachel yeah I'm gonna do
left mouth right ready okay hi hi how
wow oh I'm looking over her shoulder it
works you guys
wait did you do the whole triangle yeah
I'm dizzy I don't know hold on give me a
second would anybody try this because I
gotta tell you I just watched Ross do it
over Rachel's shoulder and it's um it is
very sexy it is very come hither I think
it could really work try it on me
that works yeah I mean I mean I'm not
even into it and I was a little into it
a little into it I mean
would anybody could hear my own shapes
hold it I like when you do it
she's funny a trapezoid learning
trapezoid yeah
so good
all right next well here's a question
have you ever looked at your dog all
snuggled up in your little doggy bed and
just wish you could climb in there with
them well according to Forbes two
College classmates thought about it and
then they brought it to life it's called
the plus full and it's the world's first
first dog bed built for humans look at
that
and uh guess what Drew and Rachel I have
a little surprise for both of you bring
them on out
[Applause]
get in here
there is no question that I'm into this
my dog buries a lot of socks in this so
oh my gosh so great
oh my God is it comfortable
[Applause]
all right well if they're going to stay
cuddly and cozy we want to say Happy
Birthday To Rachel thank you so much
happy birthday Rachel
we love you 222 babies are celebrating
their birthday and coming up what does
the ultimate Drew Barrymore birthday
cake look like we're gonna find out and
it's a competition
[Music]